the multiverse it's dangerous  i could use an avenger  it's about time you showed up  on may 6th  enter a world  of strange try not to break the  multiverse stephen  oh come on  dr strange in the multiverse of madness  video pg-13 you can see it in premium  large format in imax tickets on seal now  doctor strange i always suspected this  day would come  because you always suspected this day  would come i'm ready  on may 6th  nothing can prepare you  for the mind-bending  descent into madness this is the only  way  doctors drink to the multiverse of  madness ready pg-13 seed in premium  large formats and imax  [Music]  this universe  is only one of an infinite one  mr strange  [Music]  who are you  in this vast multiverse  stephen strange your reckoning is long  overdue  stranger  [Music]  only beaters may 6 tickets on sale now  you